[Music]
the interior portion of Britain is
inhabited by those of whom they say that
it is handed down by tradition that they
were born in the island itself the
maritime portion by those who had passed
over from the country of the Belgae for
the purpose of plunder and making war
almost all of whom are called by the
names of those states from which they
being sprung they went thither and
having waged war continued there and
began to cultivate the lands the number
of the people is countless and their
buildings exceedingly numerous for the
most part very like those of the Gauls
the number of the cattle is great they
use either brass or iron rings
determined at a certain weight as their
money tin is produced in the Midland
regions in the maritime iron but the
quantity of it is small
they employ brass which is imported
they're as in goal is timbre of every
description except beech and fir they do
not regard it lawful to eat the hair and
the [ __ ] and the goose they however
breed them for amusement and pleasure
the climate is more temperate than in
Gaul the colds being less severe
[Music]
the island is triangular in its form and
one of its sides is opposite to Gaul one
angle of this side which is in Kent with
a almost all ships from Gaul are
directed looks to the east the lower
looks to the south this side extends
about 500 miles another side lies
towards Spain and the west on which part
is Ireland less as is reckoned than
Britain by 1/2 but the passage from it
into Britain is of equal distance with
that from Gaul in the middle of this
voyage is an island which is called
Moana many similar islands besides are
supposed to lie there of which Islands
some have written that at the time of
the winter solstice it is night there
for 30 consecutive days we in our
inquiries about that matter has attained
nothing except that by accurate
measurements with water we perceive the
nights to be shorter there than on the
continent the length of this side as
their account states is 700 miles the
third side is towards the north to which
portion of the island no land is
opposite but an angle of that side looks
principally towards Germany this side is
considered to be 800 miles in length
thus the whole island is about two
thousand miles in circumference the most
civilized of all these nations they who
inhabit Kent which is entirely a
maritime district nor do they differ
much from the Gallic customs most of the
inland inhabitants do not sow corn but
live on milk and flesh and are clad with
skins all the Britons indeed die
themselves with woad which occasions a
bluish color and thereby have a more
terror
appearance in fight they wear their hair
long and have every part of their body
shaved except their head and upper lip
10 and even 12 have wives common to them
and particularly brothers among brothers
and parents among their children but if
there be any issue by these wives they
are reputed to be the children of those
by whom respectively each was first
espoused when a virgin